So maybe, maybe this will make you feel better Charles. So
there's we can actually, you know, when all else fails, change
the problem. So let's say that instead of trying to learn
the way we were describing it before, we're going to change the rules.
We're going to say we're going to use a learning formalism that's sometimes
referred to as mistake bands. So here's how the things work
in mistake bands, the learner is sitting around and input arrives.
And then the learner gets to guess an answer for that input.
So the learner the, maybe the learner chose the input or
maybe it came from a, a helpful teacher or maybe a malicious
teacher, turns out it's not going to matter. But the input's going to show
up. The learner's going to guess the answer, so it doesn't have to
now guess the hypothesis and get that right. It just has
to get the. The output correct for this input. If the learners
wrong, then we're going to charge it a point and tell it,
that it was wrong and then it goes up to one and
we repeat this and so, this is going to run forever and what we're
going to do is bound the total number
of mistakes made, into infinity. Right? So,
were going to keep playing this game forever. And we want to say it'll never
make tot total number of mistakes will never be larger than a certain amount.
>> So this is giving the learner some
new powers, right? So the learner now is guessing
answers. And all we have to guarantee is
that if is guess is wrong, it better learn
a heck of a lot from that. Hmm.
>> Otherwise if it even if it doesn't know much
if it guesses right that's fine. It doesn't have to learn.
>> Okay. I see. So, so in the case before so long as I had been
guessing false I would have been okay even
if I didn't know what the hypothesis was.
And then the moment I got a one, I got a true, I could actually learn
something. Then I should learn something and try
to do better guesses from that point on. Okay.
>> Outstanding, yes, exactly so.
So let's turn that into an algorithm. So here's
an algorithm that's really simple and actually can learn very
effectively for these mistake bound problems. So it, it
works like this. It starts off in this weird state
where it imagines in the formula that every variable
is present. In, in both it's positive and negated for.
Right, which is kind of weird. And so what that, that
would mean is the formula is x1 and not x1.
X2 and not x2. X3 and not x3. X4 and not x4. X5 and not x5. So
any input that it gets, it;s always going to produce
the same answer, right? What, what is that answer.
>> False. False, right, so it's going to keep saying false, for a
long time. Until at some point, it actually could be right. Each
time it's right, it's actually not getting charged any mistakes for that.
It's just that at some point, it's going to get an input that
the correct answer is true. It's going to
say false, and it's going to have made a
mistake. So let's say that this here, here's that example. X1 is true. X3 and X4
are true, and the other two are false,
and the learner said false, but the answer
was actually true. So if the answer to this one is true, what do we know?
>> We know that one zero. Wait we know that 0100 1, which is the
opposite of what you're saying could not be a part
of the formula. So we could remove that from our formula.
>> okay. That's one way to think of it. Couldn't quite think of it that way.
>> But am I right? Yeah, if this is what you meant. so...
>> [LAUGH]
>> Uh...the first variable, the x1 not cannot be in the formula. Cause
if it was, there's no way that this would've been able to produce true.
>> Right.
>> So we can erase x1 not. We can erase x2... in a positive
form, because of the second bit. We can, the third bit says that X3, if it's
in there, it can't be negated. We don't know if it's in there, but we know it
can't be negated. X4 Is the same. And x5, if it's in there.
>> Right
you get rid of the positive. Yeah, that's what I meant. That's
why I wrote down the opposite of everything that was up there.
>> Yeah, and that is what we're left with. Okay,
it's not exactly what the algorithm says, but it, it produced
the right answer in this case. Alright, so now, now
what is it going to do? Now it's going to continue to say
no, unless it sees. This particular bit pattern, right, this
is the only thing that will ever predict true on and
it will always be right,when it does that because we
know that is the correct answer for that. But let's so,
so it's going to guess no everywhere else and so let's say it gets
something wrong again and let's say it gets one zero, one one, one wrong.
So in this particular case, it's going to guess no, and we say, I'm sorry,
the answer is yes. All right, so now what does it know from that?
>> Well, I'm just reading your algorithm now. And
I'm just going to do what number three says.
>> All right. That's a good idea. It says if we're
wrong, which we are in this case, set all the positive
variables that were zero to absent. All
the positive values that were zero, there are
none of those and said all the
negative variables that were one, to absent, alright.
So then that was x5, x5 is there in its negated form, but it's actually a one in
the input, so we're going to turn that away to absent. Alright.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So and that's the same thing that you did when we were
looking at the problem before, you said if you have two answers, where the,
two inputs where that output is both true, any bits that are
different in those two patterns, must be not part of the formula.
>> Right.
>> Alright, so now we've definitely, X5 is
not in the formula and that's actually correct there's,
there's at no point in the future where
we have to revisit that. In this other cases
we are not quite so sure. It could be that they're, in there or not in there.
And, so each time that we get one
wrong, we're going to move something from negated to absent.
And when we do that, that thing is always going to be correct.
So at most we can move K things from negated or positive to absent.
>> Oh! So if I. . Think about, oh, so
even if we may have to see in fact, every,
even if we may see an exponential number or examples.
We will never make more than k plus one mistakes.
>> Perfect.
>> And so that's exactly what I wanted
to do before, right? So, if, if I'm a teacher, if I'm a good teacher in this
case, then I can basically, and I knew
that you started out assuming that everything was false.
>> That you know, all variables were there in both their positive or
negative form, I can just give you one example that is true. And that
would let you eliminate half of the formula right away, and then I could
just keep giving you examples that are
true but only with one variable difference
each time. And then eventually you would learn it.
So, then the total number of samples you would
need would also be k+1 if I know how
you're starting out as a learner. Does that make sense?
>> If we charge things by mistakes.
>> No. But even if we don't charge things by mistake. If I'm
a teacher who's trying to give you the best examples and I know that
as the learner you're starting out with a formula that is x one
and not x one, x two and not x two. Like you said before.
Then I could just give you the first example that is
true. That'll eliminate half of those literals. And then only give
you true examples from that point on, where only change one
of the variables that are left, and you'll know that you can
make them absent to get rid of it, and so, just
as you can only make k plus 1 mistakes, I could
give you exactly the right k plus 1 examples. If I
know how you're starting out as a learner. If I don't know
that, then I have to do the k plus 2 that you showed before.